NATO is prepared to continual training
and capacity building when the situation
permits we remain strongly committed to
the fight against international
terrorism at our meeting today the
United States also briefed on the
regional situation following recent
attacks on coalition forces in Iran and
the strike against general Soleimani
for years all allies have expressed
concern about Iran's destabilizing
activities in the wider Middle East
region we agree Iran must never acquire
a nuclear weapon we share concern about
Iran's missile tests yes it was a very
brief press conference by and
Stoltenberg the NATO secretary-general
he had convened this emergency meeting
of NATO's 29 ambassador's to discuss the
rising tensions between the United
States and Iran to discuss the situation
of course the United States is a NATO
member and Sultan Berg said that there
was a briefing by the US ambassador to
the other ambassadors to really talk
about Washington's perspective why it
had carried out this action against
general Soleimani Stoltenberg said he
can share the information that the u.s.
Ambassador had given with of course the
press but he said that NATO members felt
that they had been a NATO ambassadors I
should say felt that they had been
adequately briefed he said also that in
the past NATO allies had been very
concerned by Iran's actions in the
region which he called destabilizing
that in the past NATO has condemned some
of those actions but he did say that all
NATO members were really quite United
and calling for a de-escalation of
tensions trying to urge all sides to
show some restraint now in terms of the
NATO military the NATO troops that are
actually in Iraq this was one of the big
questions going into this meeting what
will happen to the NATO mission in Iraq
or Stoltenberg said that although
operations have been suspended those
troops are in Iraq training Iraqi
soldiers encounter ISIL of
relations and combat he said that fed
NATO had suspended that mission but that
it wants to continue that a mission it
was very important work and he said that
those NATO forces are of course in Iraq
had the request of the Iraqi government
now we know that the Iraqi parliament
recently requested all foreign troops to
leave the country Stoltenberg said for
the time being those NATO troops will
remain there so it's already clear what
will happen but he said that Ally NATO
allies were very intent on trying to
keep that mission in place so the
Secretary General said that the u.s.
provided the rationale for the attack
and it seemed that the NATO members were
happy with what they heard but he
couldn't tell us that the public what
that rationale was but went on to say
that Iran must refrain from further
violence and an escalation that's right
Stoltenberg made it very clear that in
the past nato has repeatedly called upon
Iran to show restraint has condemned
Iran for Stoltenberg said was
destabilizing actions in the region
destabilizing influence
now of course Altenburg said that he
couldn't share with us with the public
with the press exactly what had gone on
in that room between those ambassador's
you can only imagine it would have been
a very interesting conversation indeed
as the u.s. Ambassador explained exactly
what was the game plan perhaps the
strategy behind the u.s. decision to
kill general Soleimani Bart Stoltenberg
said that allies were very were had Ally
said that they were united and
understanding why this had taken place
now what the opinions were beyond that
we don't know only that NATO ambassadors
have said that they are United and
calling for restraint for a
de-escalation of tensions because nobody
wants to see said Stoltenberg an all-out
conflict